alles klar leute da gibt es sich auch
die menschen wie den jungen mann ihre
schicken in bild könntest du als frau
seien alles klar schaue ich dieses bild
mal an und dann sagt mir doch einfach
mal ob ich das als frau sein könnte
darüber klebt und herzlich willkommen zu
einem neuen video unter meiner rechten
videos habe ich euch gebeten die kritik
zu geben das heißt mit mehreren
vorschlägen den kommentaren gibt und ich
geh jetzt heute darauf einwählen partner
angesagt der hintergrund muss man all
gemacht werden also leute ich wetten
würde mein großes idol kräftig
nachgedacht und da ist mir aufgefallen
dass kehrst du hier gerne mal sagt wenn
irgendwas fährt somit aus frankfurt
statt immer auf inferno oder wenn er in
berlin ist sagt natürlich voraus website
bietet auf berlin schaufenster direct
damit ihr uns absehen können um
natürlich ein video zu dem feuer in dem
moment habe ich mir gedacht es wäre
eigentlich echt mal interessant zu sehen
was käfig dafür installierten apps dazu
kommt quasi wie viele mädels wirklich
solche angebote eingehen und da habe ich
gedacht okay ich habe gar nicht möglich
seine videos nicht oft wird das gibt was
der fan achten bekommt muss ich euch ja
eigentlich noch mehr interessieren was
ich für nachrichten bekommen story läuft
die hilfe muss ich dafür entschuldige
ich hab gestellt auch keine mädels auch
gefunden irgendwie nach bilder oder
sonstige eindeutige anfrage auf ins land
zu schicken
eigentlich machen sagte kefer
ich gehe in dem wiener leute ich war
heute abend nach köln alle mädels die in
köln wohnt schreibt mir doch mal auf
instrument nämlich abstoßend wie gesagt
der gedanke dahinter das ist zeigen
möchte dass man sofern akten bekommen
weil ich glaube ich keine freiheit
draußen wirklich ein klares bild davon
hat was man für nacht könnte damit
bekommt das youtube deswegen firma was
für eine sache ist die mega auch
passiert ist dass man die solchen achten
bekommt das heißt man über welchen
gruppen hinzugefügt wird wo man keine
einzige person kennt also wirklich keine
und die da halt einfach ja ein
hinzufügen und wie kommt man als man zum
beispiel dieser lustigen
durch die bilder oder solche bilder
aber es gibt ja viele leute die einfach
fragen haben außerdem haben die viren so
zum beispiel dieser junge mann hier ist
ein oster special gesagt hey leute ich
bin wieder einkehrt war das ernst
gemeint
jetzt wird es ernst gemeint ich war in
dem moment der festen überzeugung dass
ich tatsächlich selbst heftig bin und
dieser typ aus linz nicht hier sondern
in dem moment war ich einfach dass wir
wirklich wissen ob ich ernsthaft gedacht
habe dass sie in dem moment fit bin
aber was cooles leute es gibt nicht nur
diese gruppen die komische namen haben
nein es gibt auch gruppen die wirklich
schönen namen hat die führende namen und
die namen haben wie einfach supergut
partnerin draufklicken sich denkt genau
da bin ich einfach zum beispiel kaffee
wurst ich bin tatsächlich in einen
gruppenchat er heißt kag wurst was vor
spieler sowie nicht jedes freue mich
jedes interview titel natural beutel der
mailings finger die gruppe taktlos und
alle schreiben in dieser gruppe auf
englisch wollte winter hinterlässt
disney magic so gut für mich gibt den
gruppen bei denen der inhalt eine hohe
qualität auch personen bei denen der
inhalt eine hohe qualität und die
schreiben dann so bewegende und
tiefschürfende nachrichten wie hey leute
die sich wirklich lange gedanken machen
leute ich habe jetzt gar keine scheiße
sondern wirklich leute nicht lange
gedanken machen und danach schöne gute
nachrichten schreiben möchte hier
sebastian diemer eben zu der diskussion
über den inhalt einer videos äußern
vielleicht bringt er war an deiner
stelle würde ich vermutlich aber das
machen worauf schlüpft habe und wenn du
keine game bietet er machen möchte würde
ich wahrscheinlich verlassen auf der
seite selbst entscheiden ob die youtube
er als jockey und wirklich viel deine
videos anschauen oder ob wir das machen
was ihr spaß macht damit klar kommen
kann ist dass wir möglicherweise weniger
loszukommen also das gibt auch leute das
macht einfach so für mich die mischung
aus versteht hier einfach so eine
mischung aus leuten die einfach bewusst
in die bescheuerte bewusst lustig sind
dann leuchten die nicht bewusst
bescheuert sind die retter sind diese
sind und dann läuten die eben auch was
wäre sinnvoll es weiter
die ganze bandbreite von von deutliche
weiteren personen die mit den eltern
sind vielleicht für den leser kindischen
die mit nehmer sind zudem sehr
kindischen 23 sind und sebastian heißen
diese mischung macht einfach so der
community für mich aus aber leute waren
wer zuständig nicht die gebildeten
gruppen würden auch nicht bei vielen
sachen die momente fähigkeit richtig
abgeht findest du gern und zwar wenn
leute einschreiben
hey du wurdest mir gerade hierbei and
again vorgeschlagen und du siehst
sympathisch aus kenne dich zwar nicht
aber wollte mal das bewusstwerden ok
alles klar dass ich nicht losgeworden
was mach jetzt dass gute leute sagt sie
kennt mich nicht die kämpfe ich nicht
von youtube das heißt ich kann das hier
einfach ein youtube-video einbauten sie
wissen wenn sie die wahrheit gesagt hat
wenn sie nicht die wahrheit gesagt hat
mich tatsächlich schon kannte sie wird
aber manchmal klappte ganz ehrlich ich
weiß auch nicht so wirklich was ich
darauf zu antworten weil in solchen
momenten alles absolute highlight aktive
gruppe verfolgt mich schon so lange
glaubt mir wenn ich sag verfolgen der
meint wirklich verfolgen
seitdem ich ins bürger machen sich aber
kaum public ist diese gruppe immer in
mein nachrichten und die heißt lachen
krachen und da stehen so sachen wie
nachhaltig habe 24 strafe aus keine
ahnung warum nee ich wollte ich mal
schauen wie es läuft
ich bin mit allen b gelaufen und hab
zwar in gedreht und um rausgeflogen
super leute da kann ich auf jeden fall
mit schreiben weil ich ganz genau weiß
wovon die karte lokales carlotta
fackiner dass die minimalste jetzt mit
nacht bekommen von der seite
die heißt einfach yanar ist perfekt es
ist eine gemeine lüge der name der seite
an sich ist eine lüge alles leute da
gibt es sich auf die menschen wie den
jungen mann ihre schicken im bild von
irgendeiner solches mal könntest du als
frau sein
alles klar heute schaue ich dieses bild
mal an und dann sagt mir doch einfach
mal ob ich das als frau sein könnte weil
ich finde dass ist einfach irgendein
mädel ist die hat vor die hamster backen
man also leute hier merkt man muss auch
willst du denn auch alles gefragt werden
wenn bei den flügen geht muss man darauf
ein
stellt sein dass man richtig aus der
bahn geworfen wird von dem ab was das
für kettenbrief die nacht in zülpich
ihnen deswegen zeige ich euch jetzt mal
nicht mit dem original klar wo alle
daten dass von diesem video ich hoffe
ich halte mich jetzt nur noch
abgehobenheit vorher in diesem sinne
lassen daumen nach oben da oder zwei
wenn wir wollten sagte 29 hintergrund
gut